convierte la ecuación logaritmo en base
4 de dos igual a un medio en una
ecuación exponencial y bueno lo primero
que quiero que te des cuenta que aquí
dice el logaritmo en base cuatro dedos y
qué quiere decir eso que nosotros
tenemos la base que es 4 y lo que nos
preguntamos es a qué potencia tenemos
que elevar el 4 para que nos dé 2 y la
respuesta es que el 4 lo tenemos que
llevar a la potencia un medio para que
nos dé 2 por lo tanto el logaritmo en
base 4 dedos es igual a un medio porque
lo que estamos haciendo aquí es cuál es
la potencia que tenemos que elevar al 4
para que nos dé 2 y si esto lo
escribimos de forma exponencial vamos a
obtener que 4 es decir mi base si lo
elevamos a la potencia un medio esto me
va a dar de resultado 2 y eso es cierto
y ya están aquí lo tenemos como una
ecuación exponencial y aunque las dos
ecuaciones representan lo mismo no salen
de la misma manera aquí yo digo 4 cuando
lo elevó a la potencia un medio
2 mientras que arriba cuando estoy
leyendo el hogar de un base 4 dedos es
igual a un medio lo que estoy leyendo es
4 cuando él elevó a qué potencia me da 2
y la respuesta es un medio es decir
cuando yo veo un logaritmo lo que estoy
pensando es la base elevada a que
potencia meta el valor que está adentro
de mi logaritmo mientras que abajo tengo
que 4 elevado de un medio me da 2